Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Oui, vous avez lu le titre de cette vidéo :
Donc vous avez le temps du jingle pour imaginer
comment les chercheurs ont pu arriver
à une telle conclusion.
C'est vrai qu'étudier les émotions des poissons
et discuter de leurs peines de coeur
on va pas se mentir, c'est pas facile.
Ah bon ? mais attends
mais comment ça elle t'a trompé, Rodolphe ?
Mais enfin qu'est ce que t'as fais ?
Pour étudier les chagrins d'amour chez les poissons
une chercheuse de Dijon a imaginé une expérience
qui permet de connaître l'état émotionnel
dans lequel se trouvent les poissons
sans avoir à récolter leurs témoignages.
L'équipe de recherche s'est interessée
au cichlidé zébré, un petit poisson tropical.
L'idée est de placer ces poissons
devant une situation ambiguë et
d'observer leur réaction.
C'est un peu comme si je vous plaçais
devant ce verre qui est un erlenmeyer
Erlenmeyer, Deutsche qualität !
et que je vous demandais
s'il est à moitié vide ou à moitié plein.
En fonction de votre
réponse, qui sera optimiste ou pessimiste
on saura si vous vous trouvez
dans un état émotionnel
plutôt positif, ou négatif.
Les chercheurs ont commencé
par entraîner leurs cichlidés
à ouvrir une boîte qui possède un couvercle.
Ils ont habitué les poissons
à la présence de cet objet
et ont suscité leur intérêt
en y cachant une friandise.
Petit à petit les poissons sont devenus
de plus en plus doués pour ouvrir les boîtes.
Cet exercice est coûteux pour le poisson,
c'est fatigant et ils s'exposent
aux potentiels prédateurs qui pourraient être
dans son environnement.
Donc il faut que la récompense vaille le coup.
Dans le cas des cichlidés c'est un petit ver.
Miam miam miam !
C'est un peu leur chips à eux.
Les chercheurs ont ensuite entraîné les cichlidés
à distinguer les boîtes
qui contiennent de la nourriture
de celles qui n'en contiennent pas.
La boîte au couvercle noir, posée à gauche,
contient des friandises
alors que la boîte au couvercle blanc,
posée à droite, n'en contient pas.
Au bout de quelques jours d'entraînement,
les poissons ne vont ouvrir
que les boîtes qu'ils ont identifié
comme contenant des friandises
et s'ils se déplacent pour ouvrir des boîtes
ne contenant pas de friandises
c'est au bout d'un long moment.
Évidemment les chercheurs ont aussi
entraîné des cichlidés
avec des boîtes aux positions
et aux couleurs différentes
pour s'assurer que ça n'avait pas d'influence
sur le choix du poisson.
Bon. C'est quoi le lien avec le sentiment amoureux ?
On va y venir, un peu de patience.
Toute cette préparation donne aux chercheurs
un moyen de tester l'optimisme des poissons
Les chercheurs mettent alors
les poissons face à une situation ambiguë :
Ils déposent au centre de
l'aquarium, une boîte au couvercle gris
Cette boîte est donc un intermédiaire
entre les boîtes
contenant des friandises et les boîtes vides.
Le poisson peut donc l'interpréter
soit de manière optimiste
et aller l'ouvrir dans l'espoir d'y trouver une friandise
soit de manière pessimiste et l'ignorer
pensant qu'elle n'en contient pas.
Plus le poisson est optimiste,
plus rapidement il ira ouvrir la boîte.
Ce type de test cognitif a déjà été utilisé
pour tester le bien-être des animaux d'élevage
comme les moutons, les vaches.
Meuh oui, ça va bien !
L'idée de la chercheuse a été d'adapter ces tests
pour mesurer l'attachement
émotionnel au partenaire chez les cichlidés.
Parce qu'il se trouve que ces
petits poissons tropicaux
forment des couples stables
qui s'occupent à part égale
de défendre le nid est d'élever les alevins.
Pendant toute la phase
d'apprentissage les cichlidés
sont placés dans des aquariums
par groupe de trois individus de même sexe
des femelles dans cette expérience.
Un premier test d'optimisme
est réalisé sur la femelle au centre.
Puis on remplace deux femelles par deux mâles.
Les trois individus fricotent un peu
et un deuxième test d'optimisme
est réalisé sur la femelle.
La femelle choisit son
partenaire pour la reproduction
puis un des deux mâles lui est retiré
et c'est soit le mâle préféré par la femelle, soit l'autre
et enfin un troisième test
d'optimisme est réalisé.
Ce que les chercheurs montrent,  c'est que
lorsque la femelle est séparée (temporairement)
du mâle qu'elle a choisi
elle ne s'intéresse
plus à la boîte au couvercle gris.
Son temps de réponse est long, très long,
voire elle ne va pas l'ouvrir.
Alors que pour les femelles a qui
on enlève le mâle non préféré
le temps de réponse ne change pas.
Cette étude montre
qu'en l'absence de leur partenaire
les poissons interprètent de manière pessimiste
les signaux ambigus.
Donc, l'état émotionnel des poissons est affecté
par l'absence du partenaire.
Or un tel attachement est un des critères
de l'amour romantique.
Notre espèce ne serait peut-être pas la seule
à avoir des chagrins d'amour !
Voilà, rassurez-vous,
la séparation ne dure que quelques heures
et après leur contribution les
poissons partent ensemble en retraite
dans un grand aquarium à Beauval,
à la Porte Dorée ou dans les Ardennes
où ils pourront couler des jours heureux.
Et à quoi vous avez vraiment pensé à ce moment là ?
Et est-ce que c'était un point de dispute,
de discorde avec votre mère ?
Merci de continuer à nous suivre,
n'hésitez pas à partager cet épisode
à mettre un petit pouce bleu,
et évidemment, abonnez vous !